[Music]
yo yo yo back in
st louis at the st louis chess club
yester i want to talk about
presentate presenting chess
presenting chess over the years i mean
it has evolved it has changed so much
you know nowadays
we got everything
we got computers right we've got
all the cameras that are showing players
from multiple angles internet video
it's like audio i can't even imagine if
i was able to sit and watch yesterday
and the us chess championship had video
of that to be able to watch it live
instantly no back in the day
they had the
the kids in the russian i remember you
know they showed us in the queen's
gambit they're
actually hooking chess pieces and
putting them on these giant boards
that's right for people to follow right
but the real original i think great
great presentation for chess
was shelby lyman calling fisher spassky
pbs on pbs tell us about it well first
of all it was like from russia with love
the james bond movie
where you know the the evil character is
playing chess and you're right it's it
it's the the moving of the pieces on the
stick and there's no commentary it's
just like everybody whispering oh my
gosh that's a good move
they got their sets
shelby live and
revolutionized
chess in america chess on tv
and it was hilarious because now we
watch it we go oh my god that's terrible
uh the guy would say stop what we're
doing is that the the telefax machine is
it's spitting out a move and everybody
run to the machine and go oh my god
shelby had pieces in his pocket he
forgot to put back on the board it was
amateur hour
and america loved it they had never
chess was greek
jesus greek and here's a guy
talking
about
how important the pawn was you can't
lose that bond if you lose the pawn
maurice you're going to lose influence
over here and this was at the time when
fischer was playing against basketball
exactly the cold war era yeah maverick
american against the soviet dominance
and he played into that as well as the
whole fever of chess in america
was ready for that kind of commentary
front page news it was amazing no i mean
it's ridiculous walter cronkite
the voice of american news he would
start his presentation about the great
stories of the day boom boom boom boom
boom but before we get into those
stories
bobby fischer is leaving his magic
excuse he's number three and we're gonna
go into reykjavik and get an update
amazing it was like what and this is
fantastic and as a result of that of
course a slew of grand masters came
along yourself and benjamin is the bob
and the generation but we jump ahead and
we go to
my first time doing commentary
i'm in the kremlin in moscow the first
sporting event ever held in the kremlin
who does a sporting event in this
political institution right but the
intel world chess grand prix gets a
sponsorship kasparov is able to get that
pull as the world champion and we're in
the kremlin i'm there for eurosport
with danny
this is before danny king and i actually
tape and we're sitting there bob rice
who's the president of the
professional chess association
he says to me maurice
the russians are doing commentary we
americans we can't understand anything
would you mind going up in a booth and
just talking and explaining the games
just so that we can follow kasparov and
kramnik on stage for the foreign foreign
visitors so i go up they hook me up in
this old school
booth i'm like what's going on i'm by
myself i got on the headset i got the
microphone i'm looking down on the stage
and gary's playing crom nick and i
decide i'm not doing commentary like old
school commentary
i'm gonna do it like john madden and
mark albert
like like it's pro sports right so i'm
shouting at the top of my lungs by
myself in the room so
and i'm going oh my god
did you see what he missed this is
unbelievable right i hear that clara
caspar of a later mother mother
she can't speak any english but the
sound coming from my voice through
everybody else's headset earpiece that
they're listening in on was so dynamic
and interesting that she changed from
russian to english just to listen to me
modulating up and down so she could be
excited about the game just the drama of
it fantastic that's how i started that's
fanta that's a fantastic story nothing
similar but there's something i love
there was a match between
um
deep fritz
and vladimir kramnik in bonn germany
and you know
germany
so they had german commentators a whole
group of them
and the germans thought well
okay we're gonna have one english
commentary one english we have like r2
yusuf klaus bishop uh helmuth lager all
of these germans all lined up and there
was me like you in the one booth
so i did my commentary and unfortunately
for vladimir he lost to the computer the
deep that was the checkmate in one yeah
i go down the escalator
and this german man with the heaviest
german accent says mr
chervan uh
thank you thank you uh
i i
changed
digit
i listen you
english very good
english
schwein nietzsche
[Laughter]
and i got
the the bottom line is people
were not only interested in the chess
but they were also interested in how you
present the english and the english
words
a lot of kids have come up to me and
said i learned how to pronounce naidor
or andris
or
fianchetto the enchant though from you
and i was like what
i'm the worst
what you would
and you know you talk about that even in
this digital age where now we have all
these presentations in fancy ways and
cameras and multiple angles you still
get characters and you taught me about a
character a commentator who has this
distinctive voice oh my gosh
the way he presents sharjah please tell
us that was terrible terrible terrible
so sharjah in the united arab emirates
was hosting
the world
blitz championships the world rapid
championships and they poured all their
money all their resources
into the playing hall the prize fund the
hotels the ambiance and somebody said oh
my gosh we're going to
show the games live
you know just the moves but maybe we
should get a commentator
so there was a grand master in residence
at the charizard chess club and it's
sort of like
we he didn't even know it but he was put
there
well i've got to tell you something
i mean i'll he'll go nameless but i just
have to say he was the worst commentator
i've ever
and he would be talking like this
oh you see mob news mark news look how
he played
two bishops so nice oh my god what'd he
do he gave him two bishops
why
bob knows he know he understands
i was like you bet you better come over
here
we were laughing
but a guy became a cult figure
because he was just so awful
well let's get started hey let's do
commentary yeah you're playing a
sicilian oh come on
that's right
you don't
you should be ashamed of yourself
playing this boring chess i can't
believe this we got to go into morocco
oh my god i can't believe
look at this guy this is the guy i'm
just gonna cackle